veamos la situación en el esquí de uno
relativa normalidad para pensar
restricción de uso general
uso obligatorio de mascarilla y parte e
España el noveno país contable del mundo
dio positivo por coronavirus
autoridades alertaron que esto no se puede hacer
comparar fácilmente un país con o
demasiados que usan el método años antes
mantenme numero de pruebas pero en españa si
han contabilizado desde principios de
pandemia de 600 mil casos positivos de
coronavirus y su última dosis manasse
la contabilidad es al oeste 600.000 cm
pero es que teniendo en cuenta que desde hace meses
él mató pero smas provence placer de
pestaña lateral ahora ejemplo durante el
lanzar mi petición casi hasta
redes jóvenes ment exponencial de asti
entre pero lo que preocupa por ejemplo el
organización mundial de la salud e
Estas cartas prueban pero sabes que eres
Al llegar al cable aumenta un índice de
positividad del rey la puerta dion cerrada
por ciento y la organización mundial
de salud indica que mantener una
pandemia en situación de control e
estado entre atender lo que la estrella trajo consigo
pero luego encontré la finca
Moisés la disposición del último camino del
que se celebra en Nell de Francia
cierra septiembre si lo haces y te doy
dicen que eres tu el que pensamos eso y no eso
inteligente y dura consternación de la familia en
españa y estados 900 personas equivocadas no
lejos se llevó 29